T
HILLARY, THANK YOU.
THERE IS NEW PRESSURE TONIGHT
FOR AN INVESTIGATION INTO
CURRENT CLIMATE ADVISER FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE JOHN KERRY.
REPUBLICANS ARE UPSET OVER
ALLEGATIONS KERRY LEAKED ISRAELI
SECRETS OR CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO IRAN.
STATE DEPARTMENT CORRESPONDENT
RICH EDSON REPORTS TONIGHT.
>> HE SPENT FOUR YEARS AS
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S SECRETARY OF
STATE AND IS NOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S CLIMATE ENVOY.
THOUGH REPUBLICANS ARE DEMANDING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO JOHN KERRY'S
TIME AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN DURING
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND HIS CONVERSATIONS THEN WITH
IRAN'S FOREIGN MINISTER.
IN A LETTER TO SECRETARY OF
STATE ANTHONY BLINKEN,
REPUBLICAN SENATOR CHUCK
GRASSLEY ASKS, QUOTE:  HAVE YOU
BEGUN A SECURITY NIRNG AND
REVIEW INTO SECRETARY KERRY'S
POTENTIAL MISHANDLING AND
IMPROPER DISCLOSURE OF SENSITIVE
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
IF NOT?
WHY NOT?
IF SO, WHEN DID YOU BEGIN?
GRASSLEY ALSO JOINED 18 OTHER
REPUBLICAN SENATORS REQUESTING
PRESIDENT BIDEN INITIATE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO KERRY AND
SUSPEND HIS SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> THEY ARE VERY SIMPLE REQUESTS
THAT WE THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD DO WHICH IS TAKE A LOOK
AT THESE ALLEGATIONS, THIS IS A
VERY SERIOUS ALLEGATION.
>> LAST MONTH REPORTS CLAIM THAT
IRANIAN FOREIGN MINISTER ZARIF
SAID THAT KERRY REVEALED TO HIM
THAT ISRAEL HAD ATTACKED
HUNDREDS OF TARGETS IN SYRIA.
KERRY MAINTAINS HE NEVER
DISCUSSED THOSE STRIKES WITH
ZARIF.
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS POINT
OUT THESE ATTACKS WERE
WELL-KNOWN AND EVEN THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGED
THEM.
IN AN INTERVIEW ON CNN, BLINKEN
SAID, QUOTE:  THESE THINGS WERE
SO SECRET THAT THEY WERE ALL
REPORTED IN THE PRESS AT THE
TIME.
SO IT IS UTTER NONSENSE AND IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE THAT PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO TRY AND PLAY
POLITICS WITH THIS.
OTHER REPUBLICANS HAVE REQUESTED
INVESTIGATIONS, INCLUDING THOSE
ON THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
THEY A REVIEW OF KERRY'S
SECURITY CLEARANCE AND ALL
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO HIS ACCESS
TO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
SENATOR GRASSLEY IS ALSO
REQUESTING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATE KERRY.
A SPOKESPERSON SAYS THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED THE SENATOR'S LETTER
AND HAS NO FURTHER COMMENT.
NEXT WEEK REPUBLICANS WILL GET
THEIR CHANCE TO QUESTION KERRY
DIRECTLY.
HE IS SCHEDULED TO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE HOUSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CLIMATE
POLICIES.
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY EXPECT TO
ASK HIM ABOUT OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL.
BRET?
>> Bret: RICH, WE ARE LEARNING
NEW TIMELINE FOR WHEN THE 2015
NUCLEAR AGREEMENT WITH IRAN
COULD BE RESTORED?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
DURING THESE NEGOTIATIONS A
SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
SAYS THAT COULD HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS THOUGH IT DEPENDS
ON WHETHER IRAN WILL AGREE TO
CURB ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
THE OFFICIAL SAYS THEY ARE STILL
GAPS BETWEEN THE U.S. AND IRAN
AS THESE NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE.
OPPONENTS OF THE DEAL SAY THEY
ARE LOOKING AT WHICH SANCTIONS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD
AGREE TO LIFT.
REMEMBER, IT WAS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND ITS MAXIMUM
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN THAT PUT
SUBSTANTIAL NEW SANCTIONS ON
AGAINST IRAN.
THOSE ARE LARGELY STILL IN
EFFECT